ciao amici io sono la città non importa
non sei a scuola l'hiv aids si era tutti
ragazzi benvenuto questo video sono con
te da teco oggi giocheremo un gioco
simpaticissimo che si gioca in due per
quello ce l'ho perché io in realtà gli
amici distrutto per fare che
impressionano poi tutti a casa
si chiama giraffe svolge in overlay e ti
spiego herat a questo è un gioco dove
devi giocare a pallavolo non bello
girano per quello che invito perché si
può giocare solo su un computer nella
stessa stanza ha capito comunque sono
bellissime con gli piace le giraffe al
design incredibile tu sei lei se insieme
la realisti tasti capua niente ma non a
chiave il signor enzo le freccette
guardate come la migliore aspetto
un'ottima nuclei hai fatto punto 26
berna costa si metta questi tagli si sa
cosa devi devi fare esatto come me che
ci allunga le gambe ma purtroppo di stop
aspetta resta che una sola mozione sugli
abbassar di bigm in ballo c'è qualcosa
ma aspetta una l'abbiamo fatto con la
roma ci sia il caso che ho capito o no
no no è difficilissimo e non di come
anche a occhio al casinò come faccio vi
sono anch'io del gioco
no sono presto fatti circulo progaming
una finta non ragazzo e di dargli un
certo è facilissimo ho dei problemi
nostri e mai domi spazio non evita il
peggio vita ad aiutare così 8 gamba zio
può essere così veloce del mondo perché
io sono velocissimo ancora non ho capito
decisivo a ya no ma mi sa che con questo
è un muro le liste con l'emanazione con
una voglia già possiamo fare è
difficilissima ma ce la si può fare
no non ho capito ma perché giochi o un
centimetro
oggi ho vinto cinque qua grazie al solo
adesso c'è il tuo testo la barra innalza
la mia è la mia ce ne sono
egli una comodità raiti obbrobrioso ho
mai non mi importa se la testa non
possono fermare stesso non vale come si
alza dai capelli comunità scolastiche o
dio è difficile io guardo agli o quattro
passi in un centimetro non ce la farò
mai aspetta metti piovano avanti
rispetto alla ronadinho come quinta
giornata della vita
aspettai intenzione no
olimpiadi verde dimentico di più questo
si chiama karma perdona aspetta una
diversa e non so non capisco i tasti
ragazzo morto mi hai visto
dopo di questa è una pista mai che perdi
la palla ora nuovi lime andata non ci
manca nulla
ecco le 13 ma andiamo avanti un punto
alla volta di 92 mondo plenty c è chi
sei bravo gioca la mia parte bravissima
dall'altra parte di dall'altro grazie no
madonna che nervoso maledetta tra
quattro match point per ex point della
vittoria ragazzi ora come riesco a
perdere malissimo della persona lercia
già non riuscivo io ci manca tori metti
le mani ma nessuno ha visto niente
magari se gli lasci un po di spazio
dell'atassia gioco ancora io oggi e c'è
un muro finto propri ma no no no mi
chiamo possa perdere ok l'aspetta mo
basta
mi ha chiuso la partita questo no
insomma le cinque punti va a tutti e
5mila addirittura salvo 10 21 chiamato
ho fatto un gioco così bello
però io so che se tutti perdonati guarda
che ti è stata o no no la donna l'hanno
vista anche in tibet l'hanno vista la
mia giraffa e si allunga il collo con
qualche bello da un presente che la pupa
sei tu a me un punto devo farlo vecchia
loro mandato vabbè dai fatto sbagliare
ma dove fosse l'ultima partita raga
questa la vittoria del 50 70 rosa
intanto perde vabbè dai quali tu in alto
c'è un cannone potrà sparo io e su marte
prendila dai kiss fido complimenti
pensavo che cade sempre dall'altra parte
di capua vetere ero già lì pronto a
godere non c'è di mezzo la chiosa casa
impatto nel grembo silvia due ragazzi
ultimi tre punti più su dati della vita
madonna partita giocatissimo basta non
ci arriva quale non ci arriva arriva
no si protrae vince non vincerai
pronuncia vice i quattro lo senti come
brucia madonna ea me va bene ma se
scarsissimo madonna celine 34 cervello
dice che la speranza due punti non è
come prima 44 quei verdi ma no no no no
max ceramico provvedimento è certo non
aspetta l'ultimo punto che ho avuto
[Musica]
ma da dove hai mandato
dove
si no giochiamo ancora dai software
cazzo la gara non avete idea dei tasti
voi non ce l'avete è impossibile dovete
che il cane stati a caso sulla tastiera
dei ragazzi speriamo che io vi sia
piaciuto è un gioco intelligente
finalmente visto che lo chiedeva tela
tanto ottenere molto grazie a ecco per
aver partecipato in questo video fiore
ancora nella descrizione forse il
ragazzino veramente mi piace anche la
nostra comunità nel senso che si scateni
cerchiamo passioni sei riuscito a farlo
ma si è visto alcuni gente non ci rieti
poi mio padre di fatto accade anche tu
vela ragazzi
porta
[Musica]